they are and they are not we are and we
are not I'm pardons I'll be immodest you
you read my book 300 plus pages I think
you get a very nuanced very
dispassionate view not uncritical not
apologetic a perspective of an outsider
sitting talking with Muslims telling
reconstructing their stories trying to
make some some sense of this
you know fascinating his history we see
unfolding in front of us so again in
modestly I think that representative of
the media me I think I did a pretty good
job and so it's not that there aren't
people out there trying trying to do
this in a very serious way a reporter
from the New York Times just won the
Pulitzer Prize last year for an
extremely sympathetic series of articles
about a very conservative Imam here in
the New York area I can't imagine that
many Muslims would have had a you know a
major complaint about the media
distorting things I mean this was as I
say a very sympathetic portrayal and
showed extremely serious attention to
the minut concerns of Muslims in this
country by the most powerful traditional
print outlet in this country if not in
the world just a few days ago the New
York Post had on his front page a teddy
bear with a reference to this crazy
situation in the Sudan talking about and
I think I think it's its headline
included the term Islam Oh nuts and it
was about wanting to chop off the head
of a teacher who had allowed her class
of seven year olds to name a teddy bear
Mohammed now I don't think coverage like
that helps a whole heck of a lot if you
read the article that went along with
the with the provocative image and you
saw that actually well actually this
isn't about Muslims in this country but
unfortunately people tend to blend and
confuse things and think about Muslims
generally don't understand that Muslims
hear really different from Muslims in
the Sudan who might be
all concerned about the names that teddy
bears are given and I think that type of
coverage is calculated to push people's
buttons and stir up resentments in a way
that serious readers would resist but
not all readers are all that series and
certainly not all viewers of television
are that serious or people who go to
provocative websites that talk about
endlessly about Islamofascists and tend
to blur the distinctions among people
who may truly be radical and dangerous
and intimidating to us as Americans who
are 6,000 miles away and really pose a
very little direct threat to us versus
your neighbor across the street who
happens to be from Pakistan and his
muslim or happens to be from cairo in
his muslim or happens to be from
indonesia is his muslim so the media
gets it right sometimes we're getting it
right more often and we blow it all the
time at the same time welcome to the
extremely imperfect Americans